[Musik]
auf und davon präsentiert von
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Edelweiß das da V allem cool da so
richtig
[Applaus]
azis geh
[Musik]
gar nicht richtig
mus Feuer und Eis naturp auf
Island auf Island haben Isabel und Steff
Felix eine ferienlodge mit drei
Apartments
gekauft mit einer Bautruppe vergrößern
Sie die Lodge um drei weitere Häuschen
sogenannte tiny Häuser ja
den innusbau den stemmen sie
allein jeder Witterung checkt ste dieses
Wasserloch auf ihrem
Gelände den für Wasserversorgung sind
landb
fre nach intensiven
Renovationsarbeiten feiern sie
eröffn eine anstrengende und emoale
Zeit diese fordert ihren Preis
muss sich um seine Gesundheit kümmern
und zieht sich für einige Wochen zurü in
die Schweiz
pl
dieation zT und Zeit Stopp halt es ist
genug statt das Restaurant samt Leitung
an otma übergeben zu können muss die
bisherige Besitzerin wieder Tag für Tag
vollen Einsatz
zeigen Gabor bleibt auf der Insel und
arbeitet weiter ohne
OTM ich vermisse ihm sehr wir war immer
zusammen diese a Jahre lang wir war
überall
zusammen
Familie will in Florida heimisch werden
inner Monaten hat sie ein Haus für die
Familie erstanden und
eingerichtets die älteste Tochter
eingeschult und sie haben gleich mehrere
Immobilien gekauft ihre Geschäftsidee
Ferienwohnungen vermieten eine Wohnung
an Toplage will Melanie zuerst neu
einrichten
ma ein weiteres Objekt ist ein Haus in
Alligator Point dasas zu einem beachhaus
umbauen
wollen
aber doch hier sind die
Renovationsarbeiten viel aufwendiger als
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gedacht
es ist Ende Januar in Island die Nächte
sind lang die Tage kurz die Schweizer
nutzen das Tageslicht aus pausenlos ihre
Lodge war während der Saison gut gebucht
aber im Winter kommen weniger Touristen
mus schnell überle wenn die nächste
g wenn ich recht im Kopf in der
Woche und
dann immer gerade machen dass es parat
WF spontan BU dass er den ger checken
Anfang Sommer so hoffen sie können Sie
die tiny Häuser vermieten der Tourismus
auf Island boomt auf ihrem Grundstück
wäre Platz für noch mehr Häuser s sch
frag wenn man natürlich noch größer und
größer werde dann mögen wir zweite Höch
alle bewaltig m
zuszlichstelle be wo wo tut hen was den
halt auch wieder Personal und ja es wird
dann halt einfach wieder
komplizierter und wir haben immer gesagt
dass wir jetzt das W alle
machen die er paar
Jahr gemeinsam etwas aufbauen davon
haben sie
geträumt was Arsch
WE noch ist ihr neues Leben eine einzige
Plackerei ja
jetztch
PLZ langsam alles
voll sind jetzt
Woch
let wir
langsam ist sch schön dass S wieder
schne aber das heißt
für dass er wahscheinlich den die Woche
wieder
nicht seit Wochen schon Arbeiten der
Eventmanager und die gelernte Kauffrau
am Innenausbau der Häuser wendefern
Heizungen Böden Bäder und Küchen
einbauen und das nicht nur in einem
sondern in drei
Häusern
wenn sie so Herz lieber
[Musik]
nicht mus
sich
Mallorca es ist Ende Juni immer mehr und
mehr Touristen strömen auf die Insel die
Mittelmeerinsel ist OT gemp
Sehnsuchtsort aus gesundheitlichen
Gründen musste er ihn vor zwei Monaten
verlassen
irgendwann hat es auch gab nicht mehr
ausgehalten und reiste in die Schweiz um
OT
zurückzuholen speziell wieder Z noch
nicht realisiert dass man wieder da sind
und
ja ist wieder gestärkt jetzt will er
definitiv Fuß
fassen rechtzeitig zur Hochsaison ist er
mit G wieder
da s gelingen J daheim wo man wenn man
sich wohl fühlt und nicht immer aus der
Schachtel muss le sondern wirklich mal
alles versorg und gut ist und wenn man d
man Flasche wie und
dasieen und einfach
abfahren Rauchen
okay stellt hohe
Ansprüche und neigt dazu sich selbst
unter enormen Druck zu
setzen also kan vor wirklich jetzt alles
positiv also wirklich aus gute drineh
und nicht irgendwie gerade alles
schwarzmenen oder ja ich sch vielleicht
miteinand aus das
ganzewander neue Ort neue
Wohnig Restaurant
umbauen neue l neue sprach kan nicht mit
all verständigen irgendwie mit Hand und
F got den auch aber es sind h ven also
wo man vielleicht auch nicht so D denkt
h wo man das Plan h aber ich gebe mir
wirklich Mühe und da brauche ich gab
Unterstützig dass man da wirklich Z das
Baby schuk und
wirklich Zukunft l ich freue mich wieder
hier zu sein dann schaffen wir das
zusammen einfach und wenn etwas ist dann
besprechen wir das
zusammen und dann schauen wir einfach
vorne
komm gab nimmt das Leben wesentlich
leichter oh mein Hand ist
[Musik]
heiß
tschüss viel
Spaß
routiniert aber immer noch begeistert
fährt Lil Rose täglich mit dem Bus zur
Schule gen
[Musik]
morning l Rose
tschüss seit d Monaten besucht sie die
elementary school in
crwfitville heute kümmert sich Mario
nicht um das Haus in Alligator point
denn auf ihrem Grundstück steht ihr
jüngstes Projekt ein
Wohnwagen
der ist zwar heruntergekommen dafür
kostete er so wenig dass die chas
zugreifen mussten auch den Wohnwagen
wollen sie bald
vermieten
also
wirau wieder hol das kann man machen
oder
also so kalkuliert
da businesspl berüsichtiget jetzt ist
gut ist gut gut wenn gut ist ist
gut seit kurzem nimmt auchas jüngste
Tochter am amerikanischen Leben teil
Ruby darf Spielstunden in der wakala
County Bibliothek
Besuchen in einem halben Jahr erst kommt
sie in den
Kindergarten
[Musik]
allein ohne ihre Schwester ist es R so
langweilig geworden hier ist endlich
wieder etwas
[Musik]
los bereit und so lie ist wirklich
Phänomen wo jeden Tag auf neu fasziniert
wirklich ja
[Musik]
wirklich Highlight des Morgens ist die
Fütterung der
Hühner hat in der Bibliothek schnell
Freunde
gefunden
vor hat sie schon jeden tagag sie wir
zurück auf GAM sie findet da alles blöd
ja sie hat ih kinderhart n und Freund
und und Lilos ist V auf andere Schul
gangen und und sie allein mitü und ja da
hat sie nicht so fre aber jetzt ist
besser jetzt ist wirklich hab jetzt m
finden wo man mit anderen treffen und so
jetzt Freunde gefunden und ist jetzt
komm
gut
seit dem frühen Morgen sind Isabel und
steef
unterwegs
schonch Strae ihr Ziel akureri sie haben
eine bootstur gebucht und wollen Wale
beobachten immer wieder vergest wo Frage
jaort kenen wo man Kön am besten
watching machen
und das auf die IDE brachtum fragen da
dass man
das Adresse K die Kön
machen wenn Sie die Tour überzeugt
wollen sie mit dem Anbieter eine
Partnerschaft
eingehen die Fahrt geht über das
isländische Hochland an die Nordküste
eine einsame Gegend für mich ist immer
der Winter schönste zland was am
wenigste l und L ein absolut ist und
aber du fahrst ir paar 100 Meter und wie
das nächste und da wieder und Pferd und
kan
[Musik]
nur ja ich hoffe jetzt einfach sch zu
fest festgestellt dass ich nicht ganz
immer so setauglich
bin nach einer dreistündigen Fahrt
erreichen Sie den Hafen von
akureri
[Musik]
guten
pros thank you bye by by by also man
nicht wie weß macht vi wenn man nicht
bis F m und die der W schon seehen
natürlich
cool
hallo
danke Z Stunden dauert die Fahrt auf dem
[Musik]
für okay
aber
Vorlauf der F meint es gut mit Isabelle
das Wasser ist
ruhig
so einon er Tag
[Musik]
lang
[Gelächter]
langig macht
[Musik]
das
da V schwanzfloss
mus da
vor schön
super
[Musik]
Melanie ist unterwegs nach panaceia an
der forgotten Coast besitzen die charers
eine Wohnung das Apartment mit der
sagenhaften Aussicht es ist das erste
Objekt das Sie
verbiieten
ich w jetzt nie selber in der Community
wohnen weiß so aber wohn der oberknüler
für zum Ferien machen aber ich jetzt
find schön W viel Garten h und und
alle langsam beginnt das Geschäft zu
laufen und zum Geschäft gehören auch
[Musik]
angestelltey ist ihre erste
Mitarbeiterin
zusammen wollen sie das Apartment
reinigen das Bett ist unberührt ich
glaub der Gast ist gar
nicht ist alles so
wie das ist der Gast wo mir geschrieben
hat
sieutfall auf dem Weg DAH und
dann h sie
michag Tag er also quasi ja dass Sie
dass Tag g Gag ja
sicher
und und ja also jetzthen wir eigentlich
gerade dass sie gar
nicht unterstützt von Mario hatte m das
Apartment in wenigen Wochen ne
imohyle schon mal richtig schön zum da
schaffen und da Mittagspause machen das
ist richtig schön
endlich als Unternehmerin in den USA
Geld verdienen ein
Erfolg so speziell jetzt das ganze den
starten und
Jaag ganz vergessen zum
auf die vol Stress und vol schaffen und
und ja also wir sind mit der erste
gest und ja das schön zum
kören ist so schön die Natur da das das
alles und das gemülich so ab brauch dem
ganz Stress ke und das ist ich glaub das
ist für schönste Kompliment
schön
Mel eine weitere Überraschung
bereit unverhofft ist auch win
hier die einzige Besitzerin von neuem
Wohnhaus
s wirk oh
perfect weed in house
yearsried who gna in now we really
hoping and praying that a young family
would move in so when they came it was
just perfect all love you love youk you
so have a great day than you you to fun
by by you to bye bye
byn ist unglaublichute mir jetzt der
kurz Ken will sie einfach so
herzlich sind und sie auf ein Z wir
wären jetzt nicht so mir sind halt immer
Schwizer wir sind immer so und so nein
jetzt nicht unbedingt mit de Reder oder
trauen halt auch nicht so und sie sind
halt immer sieen immer auf ein zu und
und und jeder spricht doch winkys wohnen
und so das ist wirklich das WE ganzy und
und istklich lustig das so vielernt
ja
[Musik]
im Restaurant brisas Delmar hat
Geschäftsführer OT den ersten Arbeitstag
nach der
Rückkehr
Hall die bisherige Besitzerin musste
während seiner Abwesenheit erneut die
Führung übernehmen das Restaurant läuft
prächtig
die Stimmung jedoch ist angespannt
besonders zwischen Gabor und
Corina dass auch gab vor z Wochen in die
Schweiz geflogen ist hat sie
enttäuscht alle mussten mehr
anpacken Sch
unsur beim Arbeitsamt ab und suchte
neues Personal ohne Arbeitsbewilligung
aber darf er nicht wieder
anfangen sauer und sie hat gesagt weil
ich gegangen bin das heißt ich habe es
selber
gekündigt und das hat sie nicht korrekt
gefunden ich weiß nicht gan
nicht
aberf
war
sein Servicepersonal auf Mallorca ist
nicht einfach zu finden und nach OT war
nun auch Gabor für unbestimmte Zeit
weg das war dann doch ein ganzes Stück
länger als gedacht und ja die Verteilung
ist dann natürlich auch ganz anders und
letztendlich habe ich das dann wieder
alles
alle so
Zeit für ein klärendes Gespräch fehlt
schon bald beginnt der
mittagsserven ich muss jetzt kurz
Besteck fertig machen 14 rechts vier
Mädels die bekommen jetzt gleich was zu
essen und ich a ist aber gerade neu die
müssen jetzt erstmal begrüßt werden
hallo
zusammen schön möchte schon etwas
trinken nur trinken
okay
gibst du das mit
röli mit was R strohalme okay
ja manchmal kann schwezerdutch ein
kleiner stimmungsheber
sein am Tag nach der Bootstour die
Auswanderer haben die Nacht in akureri
verbracht diese mit dem
ja
aber in akureri gibt es ein
Einrichtungsgeschäft eigentlich kaufen
Isa und Steff das Inventar vielfach
online ein
was
ja und
Schöffel und
boxck
jainkaus S und somit
kostpielig aber einen passenden Teppich
für das größere der Tiny Häuser haben
Sie online nicht
gefunden hey eine h ja ist das
das 40 auf
z doch das passt ein großes jetzt pass
ja das
passt
wieder etwas
erledigt ja
sch und ab nach
hause allerdings nicht auf direktem Weg
Islands Wildnis hat den naturbchen Steff
schon immer
angezogen B die sch der Wasserfall den
er am Vortag entdeckt hatte lässt ihn
nicht mehr
los
und
tir nicht zu wenn da in
geht der Hotpot die heiße Quelle liegt
etwa 10 m über dem eiskalten
Fjord gerade Respekt V was jetzt gerade
macht
immer alles was man kann aber er weiß
immer was er
macht
sicher schön frisch ich bin wieder super
[Musik]
über 30° hingegen ist es auf
Mallorca während der Zimmerstunde wollen
auch und G einen Moment durchatmen
sch die angespannte Stimmung zwischen
ihnen und Corina belastet
beide mein D das Gefühl dass sch und ich
meine ich schlecht gegenüber g
einfach für mich nicht
lustig und aber
on me h vorgefall das ist ganz klar und
haben
verschiedeneichtte und das K jeder hat
seine eigene Wahrheit aber alle wollen
sie das gleiche das Restaurant soll
florieren einmal mehr steht ein Gespräch
an
OT will es positiv angehen gut
ja wie das geht kan er g abschauen
täglich einetion le
[Musik]
it um 3:30 Uhr hat Lily Rose
Schulschluss eine halbe Stunde später
ist sie
[Musik]
daheim
h dank des Umzugs vom Rheintal nach
schoopi hat Lil Rose das Glück
zweisprachig
aufzuwachsen Verst ich fast alles
schon es geht sehr Sel wenn bis nicht
verst Englisch bffeln lernt auch Melanie
dazu mus mal was da we wie was
he okay dann mal da ja das
pas du
bist ja me da GT Einzel wter W ich auch
nicht weiß was es heißt also wirklich W
ich
muss translat
benut
[Musik]
ein großes liebevoll eingerichtetes
Haus Mama und Papa die für sie da sind
den beiden Mädchen ist es wohl in
[Musik]
Florida sind die Kinder im bet die
Eltern ums
gäagement andere noch
geschrieben gar nicht im Apartment und
jetzt hat s
zurrieben ja danke viel mal und
Entschuldigung sie einach nicht Kön sich
aufra zum na und so
und Stör sie schon belästigt
ü na Stress mit
dem ja
ja
ich
zurü ja aber
sieben Apartment an derten Coast ist
zu
überas wie
viel D wirklich inhalb von der er
was wirklich nicht damit gerechnet das
nichter gemacht oder so wirklich
nur was passiert also wir sind voll
überrascht also ich fre Z Projekt bis
sal Range House undigator point fertig
ist
und ja wen
wenn den kommt die Realität und und dass
man den wirklich seid jetztes Business
das ist jetzt einfach Start
[Musik]
mal den ganzen Vormittag schon FT ein
warmer Sturm über den Osten der Insel
schnell ist der Schnee weggeschmolzen
auf dem Land schauen die Nachbarn auch
unangemeldet vorbei vor allem im Winter
haben die Leute
Zeit
sten noch sind nicht alle Küchen
eingebaut noch fehlen die
Bäder aber g auch vorwärs und ich sehr
gern g bewi aber ich h wie Rucksack
nichter drückt ma jetztlich die Hütte
fertig und das ist Problem bei
mir machen
und weiß auf Island nimmt man sich Zeit
auch wenn man keine
hat
bra ja also
[Applaus]
komm
ste Englisch
ist
sie schon
frü time
[Musik]
timeer
ja ist schon lustig W L gewundig sind
und es ist sch durfgespräch der nachb
mus so also es macht e extrem stolz
natürlich zeigen und du und und
miteinand
philosophieren Ken vom Dorf er macht da
alles da ja macht
der Besuch kommt nämlich wie gerufen der
Nachbar ist nicht nur Bauer ihm gehört
auch ein kleines
baggerunternehmen und vor allem kennt er
sich mit Wasserquellen
aus Look going the water ver sem sagt
það sé Sá sem er að Bora fyrir vatninu
að athuga fyrst hvort það sé og grafa
holu og EF það er nÓg vatnar þá þarf ni
að koma og Bora já
þf
frör Nachbarschaftshilfe ist im dün
besiedelten Island eine
Selbstverständlichkeit
ja mir da immer so Glück dass man die
richtige l richtigen Moment frag und L
und jeder helfft halt da im im Dorf W
und er macht Straße zwischen mit Schnee
und das ist schon
für ja hilft
[Musik]
wo
ab 10 Uhr bereitet das prissers Team den
Mittagsservice
vor
dan nach einem Gespräch ist die Stimmung
wieder gelöst Corina kann endlich kürzer
trittenen guten Morgen guten Morgen
[Musik]
hallo ist ja soweit alles aufgebaut
alles offen alles unter Kontrolle also
alles gut bin ich beruhigt
ein kurzer Gang aufs Arbeitsamt und
garbau darf wieder arbeiten jetzt mache
ich die Bestellung von MO da bestellen
wir unsere Liköre und also die
alkoholischen Getränke und alle Zutaten
für unsere hausgemachte Sangria also z.B
jetzt hier fangen wir einfach mal Gin an
ja noch der Bombay saff haben wir da und
den hrix also we brauchen wir eigentlich
immer nur eine Flasche vorne haben die
brauchen wir nicht noch auf
Lager nachholen was er während seiner
Abwesenheit verpasst hat Kaffee haben
wir diese Woche schon geliefert bekommen
glaube ich er kommt auch einmal Woche
manchmal kommt er manchmal nicht der ist
so ein bisschen
Spanisch Moment wir haben jetzt
mittlerweile schon Jul fast fast Ende
Juni so Ende Juni und jetzt sind wir
natürlich an mittags auch schon wenn es
voll wird wird's meistens Hauruck voll
und dann habe ich auch wenig Zeit noch
Sachen zu erklären also es wäre besser
gewesen wenn ich das am Anfang der
Saison Gemach hätte machen können pöpö
alles erklären aber jetzt wenn es dann
auf einmal voll wird muss ich
konzentriert bei der Arbeit sein und
dann habe ich also mit opma besprochen
dass jetzt wo es halt ruhig ist dass ich
ihn so viel wie möglich alles erklärre
damit er jetzt auch so schnell wie
möglich genau weiß was er alles zu tun
hat wenn ich nachher nicht mehr da
bin endlich den Traum leben den Traum
von einem Restaurant auf Mallorca ich
habe zwei Bier das offeriere ich euch
okay ist
gut sehr gerne also ich bin der rotmar
ich seid ja Stammgäste hier ja freut
mich sehr se 30 Jahren 30 Jahre schon
sicher ja
m freut m ja Koffe bleibt uns treu wo
hast du mal
[Musik]
BR so B danke schön
danke nächste Mal bring nicht meine Brot
musst du für
dich das Schicksal des brises selmar
bald schon liegt es ganz in otmas und
gabos
Händen das liebes paar wird nun Tag für
Tag auch unter Stress zusammenhalten
müssen wenn du z Sch
ja du bist sehr noch immer aufin und ich
danke das Zukunft abstimmen D
dasich Freiheit h 24 Stunden Aufand das
ist nicht gut
irgendein
ma Liebe habe geht das so ja aber wenn
Liebe habe dann geht das so wie viel
Stunde wir Zusam ja aber du mich liebst
und ich dich liebe fest dann es geht
schon ja das war schön
ja was nicht wäre es schön es wird schön
das muss so
sagen sit machen
ja immer
noch
Drucker ja ich druck ja ja er ja Druck
nein g
überfahren im hat Mario den Wohnwagen in
Schuss gebracht die Schäden repariert
jetzt will er ihn am Rande ihres
Geländes parkieren bereit für
gästeas haben viele Geschäftsideen doch
nur eine Philosophie sie bieten das an
was ihnen selbst auch gefällt warte ja
gut gut got ist
gut ja ja
pas
wie
und
ja ja ich GB
gut
hin ja gut 100 m vom h
weg da
freileit verleicht ma unter zum aber
Wasser soes hinterü jetzt das anders
lösen paar Schü ma zum den füll aber jau
ist schon mal
vorhanden ziemlich
wichtig
das Wohnmobil bietet Platz für eine
sechsköpfige Familie milanie war einmal
mehr für das Interieur verantwortlich
und sie gab dem Wagen auch den Namen
Turtle
[Musik]
in machen ne fre dass jetzt das
geschafft ja
Lauf und das ist mega Erlebnis W Schlaf
und Fenster und und
so Schuhe macht nur der Papa ja
hinter in der nächsten Folge ist es mit
der
Ruhe m oder ja aber wenn sch da das
nicht weg führen ihre erste
professionelle bootour
durch das Haus inigator Point ist
endlich saniert und das Paar beginnt mit
dem Umbau einer weiteren
[Applaus]
immobiliec ige Besitzerin des
Restaurants ist definitiv ausgestiegen
froh ist Restaurant die me 100% ist
allesöst und erledigt die beiden sind
umgezogen von ihrer neuen Wohnung
schauen Sie direkt aufs Meer
hinaus Sommer auch in Island bald schon
kommen die ersten Gäste für die tiny
Häuser doch noch fehlt der letzte
Schliff trotz Zeitdruck Pflanzen sie 4
äe an es ist einfach jetzt Moment nicht
richtigunkt umum das
machen die Quelle ist ausgebaggert und
gefasst aber bringt sie auch genügend
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Wasser
[Musik]
auf und davon präsentiert von
Edelweiß